[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
who are we we are the ones who step up
for each other
i've got your back you've got mine
kindness
humility empathy it's not just talk
it's who we are it's who we always have
been
and no one can take that from us the
movement to bring it back
it started here and here
and here in school gymnasiums
community centers the living room down
the block
you'll be aware okay we'll be there who
are we
we're the movement that will beat donald
trump
welcome we're going to have to sweat for
it
we're going to have to sacrifice and
fight
we're going to have to lead everyone is
going to have to lead with
kindness humility empathy
and not just talk but action
action today action tomorrow
action until we win and we will win
if we do this together
it's who we are it's who we always have
been
now let's show them
welcome to the spiden harris campaign
event milwaukee get out the early vote
event with senator kamala harris
please welcome wisconsin field organizer
ono say oyome
hello milwaukee um my name is honestly
omayeni and i'm an organizer with the
democratic party of wisconsin
specifically working in downtown
milwaukee like senator harris i'm also a
bison as a member of the class of 2021
i'm finishing up my senior year at the
illustrious howard university
the mecca the real hu which has refined
my voice and given me an unshakable
foundation
but i've had cause to be involved far
before i
ever took my first steps on the yard my
passion from organizing stems from my
roots in what i believe
is the greatest city in the world it may
sound hyperbolic to some but lowell
massachusetts where i'm from
is one of the most special places in
the world citizens of lowell come from
over
more than 60 countries and speak more
than 50 language
some of us spend weekends perfecting the
perfect bombing recipe
some of us spend weekends dancing
bachata and some of us spend weekends
practicing
apsara some of us have a long and
weathered history with the city
and some of us have just arrived after
escaping global crises now growing up in
lowell
i learned to be open-minded and lean
into curiosity
about ideals beliefs and cultures that
were different from mine
i found that i was surrounded by
resilient people who had mastered the
art of making the impossible possible
some balancing classes and raising a
family some working three jobs to
support their siblings
some adjusting to the loss of important
people in their lives
and some fearlessly taking on the
challenge of opening a small business
they used to dream about
in another country lowell massachusetts
is where i first learned that people
shouldn't be defined by the assumptions
and the limits placed on them by other
people
but by their questions by their protests
by their resilience
by their big-heartedness lol is where i
first discovered we all have the right
to be defined in our own terms
by our hopes by our dreams and by our
vision
for the future it was revolutionary to
grow up surrounded by magicians who had
mastered the art of making the
impossible
possible now i started organizing in
milwaukee back in august and from what
i've gathered from conversations i've
had with my amazing volunteers
and voters lol and milwaukee are a lot
alike
the city is full of people making it
happen full of people making the
impossible possible
working overtime to support their family
to support a sick family
member and working to undo years and
years of legislated racism and injustice
now this election is an opportunity to
practice what we've spent our lifetime
mastering the chaos we've survived the
past four years
doesn't have to remain a pit of despair
it can become a ladder to a new frontier
an opportunity to imagine what is
possible
and then make it happen now vice
president joe biden and senator kamala
harris have nominated have been
nominated with the most progressive
platform in history
one that prioritizes things like raising
the minimum wage
immigration reform expanding the aca and
implementing community-led criminal
justice reform
now these things would empower us to
focus more
on making our dreams happen and less on
breaking out of the limits
and the restrictions imposed on us by
other people but if american history
tells us anything
it's that no one achieves anything alone
these two unwavering fearless leaders
can't begin this new chapter without
your vote and without your voice
wisconsin has already been voting for 33
days but now there are just 14 days left
for everyone who has spent the past four
years or even a lifetime
making the impossible possible there are
only 14
days left to vote for a country that
judges us based on our merits
and not our identity if you haven't
voted
already please go to wisdoms.org early
pick a site make a plan to vote make it
today and execute it tomorrow
let's give senator harris the most
incredible birthday present by making
our voices heard
now if you voted already please
make more moves before you make a lot of
noise
there are just 336 left
until november 3rd i'm asking you to go
to north
mke dems.com gotv
please keep that all lower case it is
case sensitive
north mkedems.com gotv
and dedicate just one of those 336 hours
to signing up and helping us build a
country that works for everybody
and makes life easier for those of us
who spent a lifetime making the
impossible
possible now i have the incredible honor
of introducing
the wonderful mayor of milwaukee tom
barrett
mayor barrett if you would like to take
it away
well thank you so say i want to say that
lowell massachusetts loss is milwaukee's
gain
um and we are delighted that you're here
we're delighted that you came to our
beautiful city
uh we want you to stay as long as you
like uh
you obviously hit the ground running and
you've gotten to know the community very
very well
and we appreciate everything you're
doing um we've got a lot of spectacular
people have joined us on this call but
the real real crowning glory of course
is having uh the birthday participant
herself who will be joining us later
senator harris and we're excited to be
with her on her actual birthday
i'm not going to tell you the number but
it's a very respectable number a very
respectable number
but i want to begin by talking about
what's going on in milwaukee today
because this morning i was honored to be
at the beginning of
opening of early voting the early
absentee voting
which we have expanded in 2016 we had
three locations for early voting and
this year we have 14 locations
throughout the city of milwaukee for
early voting and i was at midtown this
morning
where i saw literally hundreds of people
standing in line
they stayed stood in line for a couple
of football fields long
waiting to vote at a time when the
temperature was still
hovering around 40 degrees but that's
how great the enthusiasm was
to get out and vote for vice president
biden and senator harris
these individuals understood and
understand
what's at stake here but i was also
very very impressed and moved by the
fact that
every single person and i mean every
single person
who was standing in that line had a mask
bar
none and that tells you the seriousness
with which
they treat the cobot 19 pandemic that
we're seeing right now not only in
milwaukee
but obviously throughout the state of
wisconsin where the numbers have been
soaring
and throughout the throughout the entire
country and you've got to believe that
for many of these individuals
covet 19 is at the top of their list
because we need a leader
who's going to take this pandemic
seriously and everyone who's involved in
this call
understands what's at stake here we had
a president who at first
denied in essence what was going on
called it a political stunt thought
democrats were out to get him started
deriding public health officials
who wanted us to take this pandemic
seriously made fun of individuals who
wore
masks and even to this day is promoting
not wearing masks through
many of his surrogates and the people
who are attending his events
all of this happening on the day when we
have now had 220
000 of americans who have succumbed to
covet 19.
220 000 people well over 8 million
people
who have been infected by this pandemic
and we have a president
who's decided he's going to take what
are hopefully the last
two weeks of his real presidency um and
tour of the country
in a super spreader event we saw it in
the rose garden
uh with the nomination of judge barrett
and we've seen him not take it seriously
since then
we've seen people like senator johnson
say it's nothing worse than the flu
but then he flies back and forth to
washington dc
on a private jet after he said it's
nothing to be concerned about
because it's just like a flu we've seen
other republicans who have not taken
this seriously
and we know the impact that this
pandemic has had on this community
economically
we know the impact that this pandemic
has had on us
really mentally because of the
challenges that we've seen here in
milwaukee
with people losing their jobs with
increases in domestic violence
in domestic violence in in challenges
that we have with opioid addiction
um and we could address these a lot
better if we had a president
who supported health care and that's a
major difference between
vice president biden and and president
trump is we have vice president biden
who
wants to see us expand the affordable
care act who wants to make sure that
we're covering pre-existing conditions
and is not attacking it through the
courts like president trump is doing
with the oral arguments before the
supreme court literally days after this
election
so it is not hyperbolic to say that this
is uh just a meaningless election this
is the most important election of our
lifetime without a doubt
this is the most important election and
we know what happened in wisconsin four
years ago
the numbers were down in milwaukee the
numbers were down
um but i am more optimistic than ever
that if people
take seriously what's going on that
we're going to see a reversal of what we
saw
four years ago here and wisconsin is
going to be in the blue column where it
should be
um so there's a lot of work to be done
the polls again are open
they're open for 1092 hours before
november
3rd and we want people to get out there
vote if you've asked for an absentee
ballot
you can put it into one of the 15 lock
boxes that we have surveillance for
uh you can put it in the mails but do
that quickly no later than next monday
um and or you can go to one of our early
voting locations or if you desire you
can go to one of the
173 locations we'll have open on
november 3rd
so it's your choice we want you to be
safe we want you to be engaged
because we're going to have an election
here milwaukee that's filled with
integrity
but with healthy people voting um we've
had a great partnership with the county
and the person who's really leading the
charge at the county of course is our
new county executive david crowley
and it's been just a joy to work with
him for the last six months and it's my
honor now
to introduce to you milwaukee county
executive david crowley
mr county executive thank you so much
mayor barrett i am milwaukee county
executive david crowley and it is great
to be with you all this afternoon
to both kick off early voting but also
to celebrate senator kamala harris's
birthday
to everyone who has joined us today
thank you for all the work you are doing
to elect vice president joe biden and
senator kamala harris
as well as democrats up and down the
ticket a movement
isn't strong just because of its
leadership it's strong because of the
partners up and down the ranks who are
committed
to advancing its goals and priorities
partners who have never let up even when
the odds may seem long
and the challenge is significant
election after election
you have been out there making calls
sending taxes knocking on doors when
safe
and donating to candidates and causes
that will help move our community
forward
so i want to say thank you for that now
we all are well aware how high the
stakes are this fall
we see day in and day out the damage
that donald trump and republicans are
doing to our democracy
and the lives of working people and it
is crystal clear
how much is at stake this election for
wisconsin and our nation
because so many families are living
these realities every single day
far too many wisconsinites and americans
have lost loved ones to cover 19.
small businesses across milwaukee county
and our state and across the country
have closed their doors for good
hard-working folks are out of a job with
unemployment insurance
running out and our economy is
struggling to bounce back
the deck has already been stacked
against hard-working wisconsinites who
just want the chance to get ahead
and we all deserve that opportunity and
we and it's realized that go we need
leaders who share it
i grew up in the inner city 53206 zip
code here in milwaukee
in a family that often struggled to make
ends meet we were evicted
at least three times during my childhood
so i know what it's like to have all of
your belongings plucked from their house
and tossed to the curb and bouncing back
from that it can be tough
if donald trump is elected for four more
years it will be even
tougher with trump in charge we can
count on one things for certain
and that is a failure to act when
wisconsinites and americans need
leadership the most
but thankfully we have an opportunity
this election to go in a new direction
an opportunity to get our nation back on
track that means restoring the soul of
our nation
taking action to make health care more
affordable and building our economy back
than ever before
we can build back better our economy
that puts the interest of working
people ahead of the wealthiest and big
corporations we can raise the minimum
wage make it easier for unions to
organize
and improve workplace safety we can take
action to make health care more
accessible
and affordable no matter your employment
status reduce the power of big
pharmaceutical companies
bring down prescription drug prices and
expand access to critical mental health
services
we can listen to science and address the
existential threat of climate change
work together when we have to work
together to work towards 100
clean energy economy create the green
jobs of the future and protect our clean
air
and water from corporate polluters we
can create a nation where we never waver
on denouncing white supremacy
and form communities that are welcoming
to us all laying out a role matches
citizenship for undocumented people
doing our part to accept and comfort
refugees
and protecting our lgbtq plus community
from attacks and discrimination
all these critical issues and more are
on the table and is on
the ballot achieving our share goals
will take dedicated principle leadership
and now is the time for leaders who will
put american people before their own
personal interests
leaders who have the compassion empathy
and vision necessary
to guide us to better days joe and
kamala are those leaders
and i'm so excited to work arm
arm-in-arm with you all to achieve
victory in this election
to make that happen we'll take all of us
making calls sending texas
and doing everything else to safely get
out the vote and if you haven't voted
yet
you need to go out and do it early and
encourage your friends and loved ones to
vote early as well
everyone needs a plan to be a voter and
be a part of our effort to defeat donald
trump
we need to unite and energize voters
across milwaukee county and beyond
it is clear that the path to the white
house runs through wisconsin
and we need to dominate right here in
our own backyard in milwaukee county to
turn our state blue
this is no small task but together we
have achieved momentum victories before
and i know we have exactly what it takes
to do it again so let us recommit
ourselves to our efforts
prepare for the final days and go full
speed toward victor
thank you and god bless and now i'd like
to turn it over
to my good friend and lieutenant
governor mandela barnes
thanks so much uh david for the
introduction uh
thank you all for being here and joining
us today for as we kick off early voting
in my hometown milwaukee again i'm
lieutenant governor mandela barnes i
could not be more fired up to celebrate
the first day of early voting but also
to celebrate the birthday of our next
vice president united states of america
in a place that is absolutely critical
again
milwaukee wisconsin i just want to give
a a big thank you to the soon to be vice
president
for once again demonstrating that
milwaukee is high on our list
uh it's one of the biden harris
campaign's top priorities the senator
she spent her birthday here fighting for
our city in our state
and she also chose milwaukee last month
to be her first
uh in-person campaign stop since
becoming a nominee so
i'm starting to think that she may like
us which is a great thing
because we like her and i had an honor
to host a round
table that featured the senator uh
local business owners and we were able
to celebrate entrepreneurship and
discuss
what needs to happen to make our economy
more equitable
and more accessible and also more
inclusive for people especially who've
been left out for so long
and as lieutenant governor equity has
been high on my list of guiding
principles
along with sustainability and my
campaign and our administration has
focused on the essentials of opportunity
and that's education it's health care
it's the environment but also a fair
economy a state where
every child has a fair shot to reach
their fullest potential regardless of
their zip code
and we know that this vision cannot be
truly realized
without leadership at the federal level
without actual leaders in the white
house
arts and electoral votes as we know are
going to determine the course of this
nation and quite frankly
the course of this planet and we can't
afford to lose that perspective over the
next 14 days
and like i said we can always talk about
how awful donald trump's leadership has
stand
or just lack thereof over the last four
years
like how he still has no plan for
coleman 19 after nearly nine months of
knowing how deadly the virus would be
and also recognizing that we are in the
middle of an economic downturn
and wisconsin is being hit especially
hard especially here in milwaukee
where families are paying for his
failure to act with their lives and
their livelihood
now instead of expanding life-saving
care we see the president
in court to overturn the federal or
excuse me to overturn the affordable
care act
which was strip protections from some
2.4 million wisconsinites with
pre-existing conditions that is almost
half of our state's population
during a pandemic no less and he's also
trying to ram through a supreme court
nominee
to read the court in his favor but i am
here to talk about joe biden and kamala
harris and their plan to jump start our
economy
to jump start this nation and move us
all forward because joe and kamala have
made it abundantly clear that we will
never get
the economy back on his feet unless we
control the buyers first
they know it's not a choice between our
health and our economy but that the two
are inextricably linked
and we know that with the bi and harris
administration we have a real chance of
overcoming so many
of the past failures and the opportunity
to build back a better nation where all
working people can join a union and earn
15
an hour where health care is accessible
affordable and available for everybody
along with a secure retirement
where we have clean air to breathe and
clean water to drink
and where we work diligently to
dismantle the systemic
racism that exists in so many areas of
our lives
and achieve true justice and equity for
all people
we know that we have the opportunity to
vote for a ticket that is committed to
building our country back better
bringing
everybody along but make no mistake we
know that this is going to be a close
election that's why the work that we do
in the final 14 days is going to be so
critical
and we have to make our voices heard
this year there are so many ways to do
that there's an option for
everyone to cast their ballot and we
have to work collectively
to make sure that everyone knows how
easy and convenient it is to vote early
and as of today you can join the over
900
000 wisconsinites who have already
returned absentee ballots
and you can take action to move this
country forward so if you have not
already
please make a plan to vote uh it is easy
to vote early
you can head to iwillvote.com wi you can
find all the information that you need
in here in wisconsin you can register
when you vote so just bring your photo
id and a proof of residence and if you
do still plan on voting by mail you
should plan to send your ballot in as
soon as possible
and the last day is october 25th make
sure you get it done
long before that and you can also vote
early in person at early voting sites
across the city and of course
you can also still vote in person on
election day november 3rd but please
be sure to take every precaution
necessary to keep yourself safe
as well as our poll workers who are on
the front lines of democracy if you
you do need to make sure you bring your
id wear a mask
and if you can bring your own pin blue
or black ink preferably
and if you have any questions about how
to register a cash for ballot call the
voter assistance hotline which is 608.
and if you also have some free time we
want you to volunteer with the campaign
in the final stretch
we need you to help us make sure that
all wisconsinites have a plan to vote
and that our own friends our family
members and our neighbors and co-workers
also have a plan so please keep making
calls keep sending texts please keep
posting on social media
doing everything that you can do to
spread the word do everything that you
can do
possibly to help like joe biden and
democrats up and down the ballot
in all parts of our state joe and kamala
cannot do it alone they need every
single one of us to play their part i am
doing everything that i can do i'm gonna
leave it all on the field
so vote bring your friends and family
with you because we are in a battle for
the soul of our nation but together
we will win let's get this done
milwaukee and now i want to turn it over
to my good friend my partner in justice
and and and all things to move uh to
move this nation forward
our congresswoman wayne moore
thank you so much lieutenant governor
mandela burns
i'm always so heartened to hear you
speak you're such a powerful voice for
the state and i want to join all of you
in wishing my sister's friend soon to be
the vice president of the united states
pamela harris
a happy birthday she certainly brings
some balance to this ticket
and she'll bring talents and peace uh
and reconciliation to our country and
i'm so delighted
to be able to share this birthday with
her two weeks before
she becomes our vice president the
presidential nominee i just want to join
everyone in repeating much of what
you've already heard
the early vote has really started in
milwaukee and i was so excited to see
the numbers of people who braved
uh the the virus and the chilly weather
uh to start exercising that right
and milwaukee we can be the first in our
country uh to
vote early to make sure that we have a
plan
uh vote early you know we can register
and vote
early you know you can bring your photo
id even if it's inspired people or if
you've moved
just bring one of your bills you got a
lot of those for proof of evidence
it couldn't be more clear our lives and
the character
of the country is on the ballot this
year
we cannot afford to just sit back and
wait
we cannot with stakes are so incredibly
high
you know wisconsin communities are
facing multiple crises right now
there's a painful economic recession
going on
it's global health pandemic and of
course
uh our pre-covet conditions
uh were not good uh as well
we are really depending on joe biden and
kamala harris to help us
go back better we just cannot go back
our pre-over uh conditions
we've gotta build back better nobody
knows that more
than joe because you know joe
thinks that the good old days just
weren't good enough
so our recovery could include all of us
no matter what our race is we should get
a fair return
on our efforts in this economy but we've
got to do our work
in order to do this we've got to go vote
i will vote.com
ui information don't be
fooled don't become complacent you've
got to make sure
that you are not disenfranchised so
forget
in wisconsin you can register to vote
register to vote
when you go vote in person all you need
is that id
proof of residence and even even if the
idea is expired
or you've moved just go and bring one of
your bills
i know you got a we energies bill and
show that you actually live there
you can vote if any questions about how
to register
to vote or cast your vote don't hesitate
to call that voter assistance hotline
at
then 608-336-3232-608-336-3232 up to
volunteer with the campaign in these
final days
that you can text people so you can call
people
so that we can make sure that all
wisconsinites have a plan to vote
and that our friends and our family and
our co-workers also have their plan you
know
keep taking those calls sending those
texts post social media even i post on
social media
uh and spread the word do everything we
can to help
elect joe and kamala and democrats up
and
down the ballot oh and kamala can't do
it alone
just as uh yellow payne says we have got
to do our work to make sure that we
down the valley ballot do what the
reverend dr martin luther king
jr told us we have elected people who
will
do justice and walk humbly with
god so vote your friends and family with
you
we're in a battle for the soul of our
nation together
we're going to win it let's get it in
milwaukee and let me tell you
nobody is better to be in this fight
with us than our
own senator emmy baldwin
as you know hebby baldwin is the author
of the provision and the affordable care
act
is so at risk right now and that is
being able to keep kids on their parents
insurance until they're 21
so i'm so happy to turn it over to our
good friend and
our own senator senator tammy baldwin
thank you so much gwen it is a delight
to join you and
follow you look early in person voting
has started in milwaukee
but you can be the first one to move our
country forward so
make a plan to vote early head to
iwillvote.com wi
for more voting information now
as you know in wisconsin you can
register when you vote
just bring your photo id and proof of
residence
it couldn't be more clear that our lives
and our livelihoods are on the ballot
this november
and so so is the character
of this country which is why we need to
elect joe biden
and kamala harris here in wisconsin
we can play a pivotal role in moving our
country forward
we must make our voices heard there is
an option for everyone to cast their
ballot
and we have to work collectively to make
sure everybody
knows how so the stakes are incredibly
high
wisconsin communities are facing
multiple crises right now
including a painful economic recession
and global health pandemic
and we have another crisis a president
who ignores
all of it and has absolutely no plan
instead of preparing for a virus that he
knew would
lead to a pandemic president trump lied
he lied to the american people nine
months in
he still doesn't have a plan to contain
the virus
and as wisconsin shatters all
previous state records of confirmed
cases
hospitalizations and deaths trump said
we are
rounding the corner i don't know what
corner he's talking about
as a deadly disease rips through our
communities
he has failed to do his job on purpose
and it didn't have to be this bad
instead of
fighting for working families president
trump is looking out
for his rich friends and for wall street
interests
instead of bringing our country together
during a historic
movement for racial justice he
tore us apart instead of conceding
that whoever wins the election should
appoint
the next supreme court justice he's
ramming through a nominee
in order to gut the affordable care act
during a once in a generation once in a
lifetime pandemic
over four years he's shown that he is
unable or unwilling to move our country
forward
the good news is it doesn't have to be
this way
we have a candidate in joe biden
with the experience to help us recover
and the empathy
to help our country heal joe knows that
the middle class isn't a number
it's a value set joe has a plan to
end this pandemic and as soon as there's
a safe
and effective vaccine he'll make sure
that it's available
to everyone everywhere no matter where
you live
or how much you can pay instead of
trying to
repeal the affordable care act and allow
insurance companies to
write the rules and discriminate against
the more than 2.4 million wisconsinites
who have pre-existing health conditions
joe's going to build on it he's going to
lower the cost of health care
and instead of fighting for tax
giveaways for the
mar-a-lago crowd joe will build our
economy back better
and this time deal everyone in
so joe won't just bring us back to the
way things were
before president trump for too many the
good old days weren't so good to begin
with
in this recovery he'll bring everyone
along
regardless of your race your hometown
or your tax bracket and he'll build back
an america that's better than it's ever
been
an economy where every american enjoys a
fair return for their work
and an equal chance to get ahead and an
economy
more vibrant and more powerful precisely
because
everyone will be cut into the deal
but to get there you and i have to do
our part
we must vote go to iwillvote.com
wi to make your plan to vote early
and make no mistake this election is
going to be close
and that's why we need to dig deep in
these last two weeks
to make sure that everyone knows how
easy
and convenient it is to vote early
as we've said throughout this call if
you're voting by mail
you should plan to send your ballot in
as soon as possible
and at the latest by october 25th and
you can vote early in person
at early voting sites across the city
and of course
you can vote in person at your polling
place
on election day november 3rd
don't forget in wisconsin you can
register
when you vote just bring your id and
proof of residence
and if you have any questions about how
to register
or cast your ballot call the voter
assistance hotline
at 608-336-3232
then sign up to volunteer with the
campaign in these final days
we must make sure that wisconsinites
have a plan to vote
and that our friends our family our
co-workers
our neighbors also have their plans
keep on making calls sending texts
posting on social media
and spreading the word do everything you
can
to help elect joe and democrats up and
down
the ballot joe and kamala cannot do it
alone
they need every single one of us to do
our part
so vote and bring your friends and
family with you
because we are in the battle for the
soul of our nation
and together we will win it
let's get it done milwaukee now
before i turn it over to my dear friend
and my colleague senator
kamala harris i wanted to wish her a
very happy birthday
from all of us in the badger state now
kamala
don't tell us what your birthday wish is
but i bet we can all guess
so get ready to
blow out your candle just a second here
happy birthday kamala
now blow it out make a wish blow it out
oh that's so great i did i blew it out
oh tammy oh that's so that that's
beautiful i virtually received that and
i thank you i thank you
oh that's so thoughtful of you and um
and while we have all the friends um i
just want to thank you all for sending
senator tammy baldwin to the united
states senate um
we have worked closely together on a
number of issues she is
constantly fighting for the people of
milwaukee i can't say this often enough
the people i mean the entire state of
wisconsin i we sit in
in meetings in the caucus meetings with
our colleagues
and uh tammy is always standing up
um no cameras in the room or whether
cameras in the room or not
all was standing up for the people of
wisconsin always standing up for working
people
always standing up for families and and
really is
a conscience of the united states senate
so thank you for sending her there
tammy thank you for your friendship and
for the birthday
congresswoman gwen moore you are a force
you are a force
we serve together in many ways including
in the
in the congressional black caucus you
are always
i both tammy and you every visit i paid
to wisconsin you are there
and beforehand you you brief me so that
i will make sure that when i am in
wisconsin i am
in tune with the issues and aware of the
needs of the people
of the state and so i thank you gwen
moore for your leadership and friendship
county executive david crowley
thank you for all that you do mayor tom
barrett it's great to see you and
lieutenant governor mandela barnes i
want to thank you
the last time i was physically in
wisconsin we were there together
you convened a group of leaders
community leaders
small business leaders black
entrepreneurs it was
very insightful it was a wonderful visit
and i want to thank you for your
leadership and your
friendship so thank you to everybody um
it's great to be with you
so we are 14 days away from this
election
and um and today is the first day of
early voting in wisconsin
my birthday
that was my little indulgence um
but you know i i actually started the
day
being in milwaukee virtually i did a
number of radio interviews
and i was so excited to hear i was
speaking with
various milwaukee leaders and i was so
excited to hear about how
at the very first hour of early voting
this morning
people were lined up and i just want to
say
thank you for that because what a great
beginning
now we got to see it through but what a
great beginning
and i think it speaks first of all to
the leadership of the people i've just
mentioned
and all of the community leaders the
faith-based leaders
so many folks who have reminded
everybody
and reminded their family members and
their friends and their neighbors about
what is at stake in this election and as
joe biden always says
the thing that is at stake reigning over
all of it
is the soul of america but let's look
at where we are we're in the midst of a
pandemic
which has at this point taken the lives
of over 220 000 americans in just the
last several months
we're looking at the fact that over 8
million people
who have contracted this virus god thank
god that they
are living but with untold
still untold long-term health
consequences including
what classification they are now going
to be in which is to have a pre-existing
condition
we're looking at the fact that because
of this public health pandemic
we're in the midst of a recession that
is being compared to the great
depression
people in wisconsin and milwaukee i know
and all across our country are are you
know driving into
to food lines parked for hours hoping
that by the time they get to the end of
the line the food is still there
nationally we're looking at one in five
mothers describing her children
under the age of of 12 as being hungry
you know we're not talking enough about
the fact that we're dealing with a
hunger crisis
on top of it all um people in milwaukee
being
unable to or finding it very difficult
um in
very large percentages to pay the rent
september's rent
october's rent um so
all of this in terms of the economic
impact and then you know we're looking
at these crises that are
as a result of the covet and then we are
also dealing with the long
overdue reckoning in america in terms of
america's history and existence of
racial injustice
and we're looking at the crisis of of
climate
and what that is doing and what it has
been doing around our country from the
west from where i come with the fires
that have been raging
all across the western states to the
storms that have been
hitting the gulf coast to what has been
happening
with in the midwest in terms of farmers
and floods and
and losing a season of crops so these
are the things that have been happening
in um in our country and in addition
we're looking at
uh the issue of the united states
supreme court and what is happening in
terms of covid
and and and then in the midst of that
we're dealing with
a a a a
a push by members of the united states
congress
to ramp through a supreme court nominee
and to do that for political purposes
meanwhile
sitting on their desk is a bill
that would bring relief to the american
people
and it's been sitting on mitch
mcconnell's desk for over 150 days
and moving nowhere in the united states
senate and so
all of this in addition to what we know
has been
the president donald trump trying to get
rid of the affordable care act
in the united states supreme court
because he's had this weird obsession
with trying to get rid of whatever
barack obama and joe biden created
and in so doing if they are successful
would not only get rid of
the affordable care act which brought
health care to over 20 million people
that means
over 20 million people will lose their
coverage but
they would also as a result of getting
rid of the affordable care act
get rid of the protections that it
created for people with pre-existing
conditions
people like diabetes high blood pressure
heart disease in wisconsin 2.4 million
residents
have pre-existing conditions so this is
what we're looking at
and frankly i think that it is um it is
more than fair to say that donald trump
has has exhibited a reckless disregard
for human life
and there's just no denying that and
again when we're looking at the numbers
who have been on unemployment the
numbers who have been impacted by covet
the numbers who have been impacted by um
the
the existence of all that has happened
in terms of
um the death and and and the cover-up in
our in our country and so
um here where i am now is that we need
to look at where we are in terms of
joe's vision okay because clearly
donald trump they knew what was going on
they knew
that it could hurt people they had the
information since january
they covered it up they gave people no
indication of how serious it was they
didn't give families enough time
to make decisions about how they would
live their lives
how they would protect their families
and this is where we are
and so what we have to do is we gotta
elect joe biden
we have to elect joe biden um you know
tammy talked about it that joe has a
plan
and we have a plan and part of it is
starting with containing kovid
and you know the thing about joe is that
he has a deep understanding of how our
government works
he has an understanding of what it means
to manage a crisis
he dealt with these crises in the past
whether it be the great recession
when he pushed through the recovery act
or what he did to work on containing
ebola
joe has talked about a plan for covid
since march
and it's a plan that is about saving
lives and saving the economy
and you know joe and i believe and this
is a very big difference between us and
donald trump
we believe that you can measure the
health and well-being of the economy
not based on how rich people are doing
but based on how working people are
doing
and ours is going to be economic policy
that is about supporting
and holding up working people we will
not
increase taxes for anybody making under
four hundred thousand dollars a year
but what we will do is we will eliminate
the trump tax cut
for the wealthy the top one percent of
the biggest corporations
we will invest in people who who
need help with health care and better
schools and child care
we will protect social security and
medicare these are the things that we
will do
because we understand if we want to
build up america's economy
we have to build up working people and
the bottom line is also doing it in a
way that unites
the american people that brings us
together joe and i are particularly
proud
of a broad coalition that we have built
one of the broadest
coalitions that we've seen in a
presidential race democrats of course
but also republicans and independents
and people of every race and every
background
coming together around a an umbrella
of understanding that we are better than
this as a nation
and that we are all in this together so
that's the spirit with which
we are in this campaign and and
and the work that we are doing over the
next 14 days it is about building back
up
better it is about unifying our country
it is about speaking to our higher
purpose and ideals
and doing the work that is necessary to
remind everyone
to remind everyone that they are not
alone
we are all in this together and we're
going to get through this together
so 14 days to go and again early voting
starts today
wisconsin you're the key milwaukee
we need you and and you can register
um when you vote it's important to know
that
um you will just need a photo id and
proof of residence
proof of residence could include your
driver's license or your state id
or you know your utility bills
but it is important that you vote early
please
make a plan to vote vote early urge
others to vote early i know you've heard
it before but go to the website
iwillvote.com backslash wi
and make sure that your vote is
counted and that your voice through your
vote is heard
because listen even though some people
are trying to confuse
folks about the election and process
voting
some people are trying to suggest that
your vote won't matter
no they what they understand is that
when you vote
you have power they understand the power
of your vote that's why they're trying
to discourage you
but let's not let anyone ever take our
power from us
we won't do that we vote to honor the
ancestors
which includes folks like the great late
john lewis
we vote to honor the ancestors like
those suffragettes
a hundred years ago this year who passed
and helped pass the 19th amendment
we vote because we know what's at stake
from health care to the economy
to the standing of our nation and the
unity of our nation
and we vote because we know our power
and we vote because we know when we vote
things change and we win thank you
milwaukee thank you
don't you get that doesn't matter if
you're going over